[Music]
brianna is with us in orlando hi brianna
how are you
hi dave i'm doing well thanks for asking
how about you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um i was calling because my husband and
i were recently talking about our
finances and whether or not we should
pay our medical bills first or
or take care of the credit card debt and
things of that such and he mentioned
that
we
we don't need to pay the medical bills
because they are going to fall off in
seven years and i was like well i don't
really think that's true
so we were debating on that and i was
like well let's just call dave
he's like great
great
great oh terrific i'm taking you to the
principal's office
great
okay well the answer is uh yes and no
okay
the medical bills uh
uh the debt does not go away in seven
years
uh you still owe it morally and legally
and they still can pursue you after
seven years the what the seven year mark
is the yes part is it does come off of
your credit bureau report if there's
been no activity on it for seven years
any credit that is at that activity it
restarts the seven year clock but all
credit good and bad comes off of your
credit bureau report after seven years
except a chapter seven bankruptcy which
stays on ten years but that does not
mean that you don't owe the money
and it does not mean that they can't
come after you legally and it does not
mean they won't hassle the crap out of
you or the stupid thing pop back up in
some way just about the time you're
trying to buy a house or something so
you do need to take care of them
okay how old are they
uh well just about two years they're
from so we're talking about we're gonna
sit around on our butts for five years
and hope they disappear
how much debt is there how much medical
debt is there
uh 3 500. oh it's nothing
what do you guys make yeah
55 a year okay
okay
so it's tight we're also paying 16 16
000 on student loan debt
um we've got a little bit in a credit
card so we're just also trying to
look into buying a home for our family
and we're growing
so
yeah i know i'm a stay-at-home mom and
just want to help
in some way so i thought the best thing
i could do is just kind of start
tackling all this stuff so okay all
right so here's what the two of you need
to sit down tonight put the kids to bed
and you you're gonna have to have a
better dream than you've got
your your dream for your life is awfully
small and i want you to dream a little
bigger
okay because you and i both know you're
too broke to buy a house anytime soon
yeah yeah we're in a one bedroom right
now and we were trying to do the live
like no one else so we can live like no
one else but
we just the kids just keep getting
bigger and we
so now what you've got to do is you have
to get real serious about it and it's
not just cutting your lifestyle it's now
getting on a written budget and making
every dollar behave
listing these debts smallest to largest
attacking them in that order and he
needs to be on board about that too
right now it's just you doing it isn't
it
yes sir yeah i can feel it i can feel it
you're carrying the weight of it you're
the one trying to get this car started
and he's going well it does not pay the
bill they'll go away so he's going to be
looking at some extra work and you're
going to be looking at some extra work
in and around you being at home with the
kids
i don't know what that is it could be
something you can do while they're
napping or something else there's all
kinds of ways to create income ken what
are some of the best ways you've seen
people create income in a stay-at-home
situation like that well we saw through
the pandemic gave a lot of jobs that
bubbled up where they were all remote
and so now with the little ones that
does present some challenges but it
depends on the type of work if it is
customer service work when she's on the
phone with people and the kids may be
going crazy that would not work per se
however if it's data entry or
a lot of women are making really good
money dave now as a remote executive
assistants and so they can do a lot of
scheduling a lot of things over email
i start to look at things like that for
a stay-at-home mom where there are four
or six hours maybe even steal two or
three hours a night once the babies are
in bed now that is going to be tiring
but on the other side of this is freedom
stuck in a one bedroom a bill's hanging
over your head it's tiring too yes it is
and uh boy that'll motivate you to work
those hours because then you start to go
why am i working all these crazy hours
to get out of this one bedroom to get
out of this paycheck to paycheck living
that is so stressful because here's the
thing
what you're describing to us brianna is
uh twenty thousand dollars
changes your life
it's correct you'd be debt-free yeah no
i'm just going to use this 20 000 bucks
okay yeah that's a part-time job for one
year right he makes 55 i believe she
said she did okay so just to give you an
example
walmart right now dave
is advertising nationally on this
they're paying truck drivers starting at
90 to 110 000 a year driving a truck now
i'm not saying that's his career and his
long-term life but i'm saying okay what
could we do for a year or two years to
radically change our future and this is
the hottest job market we've ever been
in so yes we want to reduce expenses we
want to get on a budget but what could
he do
to get serious to say we're going to
change our family tree and raise his
income from 55 to 75 to 85 if she can
make 15 to 20 you said almost one year
you're free one year not five
with a thing hanging over your head
later and coming back and getting you
100 and if he's sitting in front of me
right now i'd tough love he might say
look bro uh in two months or less i
could show you how to pay off that 3 500
medical bill in two months two months of
extra work you deliver pizza
you're done walmart and target are
paying all shifts starting at 20 an hour
amazon offering 20 an hour fulfillment
centers all over the place
and listen if you have a pulse they'll
hire you
yeah
so the the entry levels what i'm trying
to say is realistically even the posters
question about it
i knew as i said that and you know what
if you've been to walmart late at night
hey
all right never mind
but there is here's the point there is
an opportunity right now to go to work
yeah and gazelle intensity includes
working a lot of hours
we talk to couples we talk to
individuals all the time on that debt
free stage over there but that's the
dream see the dream is twenty thousand
dollars gets you out of debt uh another
ten thousand dollars is your emergency
fund now we're saving for a house
so twenty thousand gets you out of debt
twenty thousand more get you in an
emergency fund on the down payment yeah
and then before you know we funded our
kid's future yeah and and now we've
changed our family tree and now we have
a legacy
so but that that you know and then
you're
and when you think like that
your your whole spirit your body
everything raises up and you have a
different view
and then you go 3 500
is holding me back yeah it's nothing
it's not 350 000 it's 3 500.
and but what that tells me is when
that's overwhelming you that you're not
above it you're not you're it's crazy
you're laying under it isn't it true and
so there's this this perception thing
yeah
and that's hope that's exactly right you
know i think of
i remember a few years ago dave my kid
went to a youth group at venice church
and they had this mud run and at one
point he stepped in this really deep
area of mud and i was watching and
laughing my wife's like go help the kid
i'm like no he's got to figure it out
but the point was is i watched my son
dave he got stuck for a moment and just
like this financial stuckness we're here
on this call what he's doing is all he's
doing is looking around him he's always
thinking is i'm stuck and this is awful
and i'm embarrassed and whatever a kid
thinks of in that moment
and that's what you're talking about
it's like oh we're month to month and oh
we'll just have to put the bills off
that's looking around ourselves when
we're stuck as opposed to looking up
going okay who can help me where's is
there a limb i can grab in financial
peace university and the budget and the
baby steps are that helping hand to
where you can essentially pull yourself
out that's what you got to be focused on
is how do i get out not oh i just got to
stay alive
hope deferred makes the heart sick yeah
but when desire comes
it is the tree of life
it's the difference it really is the
difference and so
when you set a really nice big fat juicy
dream and you do it in high definition
hd
lots of clarity on what the dream smells
like what it feels like what it touches
you know the way it looks the way other
people see it then all of a sudden
everything starts to move for you and
that's what's going on here brianna
that's what's going on